people have been making wine for
centuries this Optics order is the
future of winemaking this is the future
but never like this Napa Valley's haul
wines is one of the first to incorporate
automation into their craft this new
technology replaces hand sorting with
machines their job identified the best
fruit
I pre-programmed with grapes I thought
were perfect so it compares against
those grapes and if it's not a match
it'll pick that out so this is where all
the images are taken right this is the
nuts and bolts event this is what makes
it all possible the robot takes pictures
at 10,000 frames per second and analyzes
them instantly the picture was taken it
was accepted it was a match to what I
said was okay and then the berries will
come across onto this conveyor and be
dumped into the bins of good fruit if
it's rejected and doesn't match there'll
be a puff of air that comes and blasts
out what doesn't magic just a puff of
air
yeah so what's all this mark this is
what was rejected I definitely don't
want that going into my tank and the old
math is there was hand sorting and
people using pumps and there's different
things that affected the condition of
the grapes this allows me as the owners
like to sell me to have no diseases and
the critics why are they skeptical of
this new optics order is it just because
it goes against the tradition I think
they like that whole element of romance
a tradition of actually having people
sorting this is really the old way of
doing it this is how you do it so much I
really have my own Lucille Ball moment
Rainier old school and there's probably
enough to do I'd say I'd say there's
probably three or four bottles an
Americans drink a lot more than just
three or four bottles a thirst it's only
increasing what kind of investment was
the optics order for a haul close
$175,000 it's sizeable but you know it's
interesting compared to the cost of
labor for sorting and we're going to get
to that return in a couple years so how
do you really expect the optical sorter
to impact your business as a wine maker
quality and it's pretty cool toy eight
vineyards in Napa Valley have now
invested in robotic sorting all bedding
this wine will be their best vintage yet
if this objects order takes off if more
wineries start to adopt it are we gonna
see better wine in the next five to ten
years I think so I think every vintage
is going to be better if it goes through
the optical sorter